today on the matt welsh show the
premiere of my film what is a woman is
an enormous success no thanks to the
cyber attack meant to shut down the film
the left really does not want you to see
this movie and i'll explain why also
nascar again bends the knee to the wok
mob amber hurt officially puts the last
nail in the me too kaufman
abusive parents explain how their
two-year-old daughter chose her own
gender in our daily cancellation a trans
activist explains why you are morally
obligated to be sexually attracted to
trans people we'll talk about all that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
finally last night almost exactly a year
after we had our first development
meeting about the film what is a woman
premiered on the daily wire it was by
all measures an enormous success we
gained more subscribers in a day than at
any other point
in the company's history we had more
people watching the film than we've ever
had watching any piece of content all at
once uh the movie is we could say for
sure now a massive hit but
we knew going in
that we were wading into treacherous
waters gender ideology lies deep down
at the core of our society's dominant
religion which is leftism
it's expected that if you go near it you
know if you dare approach the altar that
you do you do so with reverence avert
your eyes keep your head bowed
uh bow before the sacred cow repeat the
necessary incantations and then and then
shuffle along move on that's how you're
supposed to approach gender ideology to
do anything else to approach this thing
with anything less than
dogmatic veneration is an act of
unspeakable sacrilege
and to actually question it to look into
its face and challenge it directly is
the ultimate blasphemy
and we all know what religious zealots
do to blasphemer blasphemers that's what
we were expecting here so it was in that
sense
no surprise that the daily wire came
under a sustained and seemingly quite
sophisticated cyber attack during the
premiere of the film as the film started
to play we were flooded with messages
and emails from members who were trying
to watch but we're running into all
sorts of strange glitches
and even in spite of this just on the
strength of people who could make it
through and access the film it was still
a record-breaking premiere for the daily
wire but it became clear pretty quickly
that something malicious was happening
and soon our tech team was able to
verify and from here i'll read from the
daily wire article about it because i
think the news team will do a better job
of explaining the specifics about this
than i will so reading from the daily
wire article it says the daily wire came
under a sustained
ddos attack during the world premiere of
what is a woman that was intended to
disrupt people being able to access the
highly anticipated film quote we've
confirmed that uh daley wire experienced
a significant and sustained ddos attack
tonight meant to disrupt the world
premiere of what is woman jeremy boring
said in a statement a million requests
per minute at the peak flooded our
system and created challenges for many
viewers the attack began shortly after
the start of the vault live stream of
daily wires backstage program which
preceded the premiere and featured daily
wire host discussing the making and
meaning of the film many users encounter
difficulty accessing the live stream due
to the malicious event a distributed
denial of service ddos attack is a type
of coordinated malicious campaign that
seeks to shut down a targeted server by
flooding the server with extreme levels
of traffic coming from bots
the extremely high levels of traffic use
up the server's resources and prevent
real users from being able to access it
so
in summary
um they don't want you to see this film
i mean they really
don't want you to see it
meanwhile on twitter there were trans
activists um
tweeting out their fantasies about
bashing me in the head with a baseball
bat there were other activists
organizing a campaign to try and take
over the what is a woman hashtag a
hashtag which by the way has been
suppressed by twitter because every time
it starts to trend twitter just pushes
it back down but the activists
tried to hijack it with various lies and
insults and defamation directed at me
they were like openly organizing with
each other talking amongst each other
you know on the social media platform
about what sorts of slanderous things
they could make up about me and they
were kind of because this is what you
can do if you're a trans activist on
twitter you could be out in the open
about hey we're gonna we're gonna make
up some uh
we're gonna defame this guy what should
we say about him and you can have that
conversation and you know there's not
gonna be any consequence
now as i said this is just the beginning
they hate this film
they're terrified of it
and uh they hate me for making it now
granted they already hated me before
this but now even more so
and why i mean anybody who saw the film
and if you haven't yet you can go to the
daily wire right now become a member and
watch it on demand it is available to be
to be seen right now
but anyone who uh saw it knows that i
wasn't lying or joking when i said that
all i do for the majority of the film is
ask simple questions i'm not going
around screaming at people
there's a little bit of that mostly at
the women's march because that was just
fun but for the vast majority of the
runtime i'm sitting down with people
and asking them the simplest and
seemingly easiest questions imaginable
questions that supposed experts in these
fields ought to be able to answer with
ease
that's all i'm doing and that's exactly
why they don't want you to see this it's
the emperor has no clothes fable brought
to life
gender ideology
lies at the core of leftism
but the core of gender ideology the core
of the core
is empty it's hollow there's nothing
there it's all smoke and mirrors in
sleight of hand tricks
everything they say is nonsense
it has no logical or intellectual anchor
it's this flimsy frail little thing
easily swatted away it can be crushed
under the weight of a question
any question at all in fact
that's one of the fascinating things
about making this film is that you know
i knew that what is a woman is going to
be a stumper of a question for these
people but what i didn't quite realize
is that um leading up to that question
really any question at all
is a stumper doesn't any question if
it's asked with actual uh sincere
skepticism
is is unanswerable to them
and this is what makes them so angry
i experienced this while filming the
documentary in fact there were two
emotions that came through in nearly
every interaction
that we had through the course of
filming and that is fear and anger two
emotions that often come packaged
together right and the fear mostly came
from the average people on the street
who you could tell
most of them knew the truth they
understood how ridiculous the claims
made by trans activists are but
they were petrified to talk about it
especially on camera
because they've been coerced and cajoled
and threatened into silence
the anger meanwhile and a good bit of
fear too
came from the alleged experts the
academics doctors politicians
who stormed out of interviews lashed out
made accusations became extremely
defensive
the moment they realized that i was
going to ask real questions
not even hard questions just questions
actual questions
they weren't expecting that because in
their minds
the relationship between a learned
authority such as themselves
and an uneducated flannel-clad bumpkin
such as myself is supposed to be one of
cult leader and disciple
they're supposed to make declarations
and proclamations and i'm supposed to
sit in slack-jawed awe
nodding my head submissively
accepting without question everything
that comes out of their mouths
the moment they realized that i wasn't
going to play my part in that
game
they became angry for example here's a
clip from the film that went viral last
night um
and uh it's a perfect illustration
my interview with women's studies
professor patrick grazonka uh and it
went off the rails very quickly
due to my insistence on interviewing the
person who was sitting down for an
interview
i mean how dare i
you have to watch the whole exchange in
the film but here's just a piece watch
this
i'm not even talking about social
context i'm just i'm just trying to
start by getting to the truth you know
yeah i mean i'm really uncomfortable
with that language of like getting to
the truth again in socialize why is that
uncomfortable because that it sounds
actually deeply transphobic to me um
and if you keep probing we're gonna stop
the interview i if i probe about what
the truth is you keep invoking the word
truth which is condescending and rude
i'm saying to you how is the word truth
condescending a root
why don't you tell me what your truth is
and you're walking on
30 seconds more of the nights before i
get up
and i explained to him right after that
that i it's i don't have a truth it's
just like the truth
and that starts this whole exchange
about what the truth is and everything
but um
i was being condescending and rude he
says the good professor couldn't define
the word woman probably also couldn't
define the word projection though he
certainly exhibited the latter
throughout our interaction notice the
remarkable contrast
between the professor and his ilk the
gender ideology proponents the people
who invented this whole thing but don't
want to talk about it
and those on the other side
the opponents
as opposed to the proponents
are incredibly open and eager to answer
questions eager to have the conversation
on one hand you have
uh people curling up into the fetal
position because i asked the question on
the other you have scott nugent who's
the woman who transitioned to a man or
transitioned to appear like a man as she
puts it herself in the film i want you
to listen to nugent talk about
the dark reality of uh gender transition
listen
for the first time in history
a marginalized group has a huge dollar
sign on the top of their head we have
five
children's hospitals in the united
states
promoting that
that's a phalloplasty that's a bottom
surgery
we have five
children's hospitals in the united
states
telling girls
that they can be boys
at 70 000
a pop in a surgery that has a 67
complication rate that will kill me from
infection that i can't sue on
butchering a generation of children
because nobody's willing to talk about
anything
i have three kids
[Music]
at the age that they're doing this to
kids
i'm not transphobic
i love my kids and i love other people's
kids and you should too
this is wrong
on so many levels
so from uh from nugent
who is the true hero of the film in my
opinion we get total
openness and uh honesty raw
gut-wrenching honesty
from the other side we get defensiveness
lies accusations
one side wants us all to talk about this
right like let's talk about this
the other side wants to talk wants to be
the one talking while we shut up
and they'll do anything they can to shut
us up
but they will fail they already have
because this film isn't going anywhere
it's on the site right now available to
be seen by anybody with a membership
and uh if you don't have one
i ask you to go sign up nobody else is
making films like this this is the kind
of content we can make and will make
we're willing to deal with whatever the
consequences are
they're coming after the daily wire
they're coming after me personally
and i expect them on the ladder thing to
to ramp that up
the good news is that it won't work it
can't work if we have your support if we
all kind of stick together there's
nothing they can do but scream and cry
if they try to escalate beyond that if
they try to you know let's say make good
on those baseball bat to the head
promises then we have other ways of
dealing with that and it will be dealt
with i assure you but outside of
physical violence any other attack fails
if we
stay unified
because that's if if you if if there's a
united front
and they're going to scream and cry and
we just say we don't care that you're
screaming and crying
this is a conversation we're gonna have
whether you like it or not if we say
that then
that's it they lose
so go to what is woman.com and get your
membership our team is uh you know
working around the clock to fight this
cyber attack as far as i know basically
gotten it completely under control uh if
you do run into any glitches just be
patient stick with us remember that
um this this fight the fight against the
the sickening
toxic madness of gender ideology
it it can be one we can beat them
we can win
i really believe that
and we have to we have to win
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
fear of out-of-control inflation is
hammering the stock market the s p 500
is having its worst start to the year
since world war ii so not only are your
savings worth less you now have less of
it on top of it uh now might be a good
time then for you to diversify into gold
the most stable asset in the history of
the world and birch gold is the company
i trust to help you convert an ira or
401k into an ira in gold and silver
that's right not only will birchgold
help you fortify your savings with
precious metals they'll help you do it
in a tax sheltered account all you got
to do is text walsh to 98 98 98 to get
started amazon stock is down 37 in the
first half of the year tesla's down 40
cryptos have been slammed and many fear
the hawkish moves by the fed could stall
the economy even more so uh what's your
plan text walsh to 98 98 98 that's a
plan and get your free no obligation
info kit on gold from birch gold they
are the precious metals professionals
all you have to do again is text walsh
to 98 98 98 that's 98 98 98 and secure
your savings now with birch gold
well as uh yahoo sports reports texas
governor greg abbott waved the green
flag ahead of the may 26th nascar
all-star race at texas motor speedway
and that provoked anger from the left
who say that this is a terrible thing
for nascar to do
and that seems to have precipitated this
tweet at least partially i mean i'm sure
nascar was already going to have a fair
bit of virtue signaling they did for for
um
for per for pride month but now they're
taking it over the top so
they tweeted this as we celebrate the
lgbtq plus community we acknowledge that
recent actions have not aligned with
nascar's mission to be a welcoming sport
for all
we remain steadfast in our commitment to
create a more inclusive environment in
our workplaces at the racetrack and in
the stands
and then they've got the happy pride and
then the checkered flag there with
rainbow colors and then they also have i
mean this is nascar
and it's not just that they're
that they're uh you know bending the
knee to wokeness
they're going all the way here because
they have the wokest pride flag of all i
mean they're on the cutting edge
this this pride flag here this is the
newest one and every single year they
always add things to it and it's it's
really kind of uh it's kind of
interesting and i think
there's something in a way poetic about
the fact that
the as the as the as lgbt activists
um get more and more aggressive and more
demanding and narcissistic and more
militant
the the pride flag itself gets uglier
and uglier
so it started as just kind of a you know
sort of gaudy rainbow flag
and then from there it just gets even
uglier
to the point now where this rainbow flag
it's got
you know it's just like a it's just it
looks like vomit
and you see the other interesting thing
that happens with the rainbow flag
is that
each new identity group that gets added
to the flag
kind of fights for more than its fair
share of the space on the flag
and so now you see what's the most
prominent thing you see on this flag
that nas that nascar
has posted most prominent thing is the
is that purple circle right there right
it's like the thing that your eyes
immediately go to
and what does that mean what is that
supposed to represent
well as far as i'm aware
the uh the circle represents intersex
people in fact wait let me look this up
right now because i wouldn't i wouldn't
want to
i wouldn't want to misgender the pride
flag itself because that would be
a terrible thing to do
um
okay yeah okay this is what i'm getting
the purple circle represents the
wholeness of the intersex community free
from colors like blue and pink that are
commonly seen as male and female
respectively
now
uh and there's also this inverse
correlation between
the amount of space given on the pride
flag
and the size
of the group that it's representing
okay intersex people you're talking
about
this tiny tiny sliver fraction of the
population
right there front and center of the flag
and never mind the fact that as we've
gone over before
and we have to continue reviewing this
um
intersex people and we talk about
intersex people we're talking about
people who suffer from birth defects
even the term intersex like everything
else lgbt people say is is really kind
of misleading but intersex we're talking
about people who suffer from birth
defects
that can sometimes make their genitalia
look somewhat ambiguous doesn't mean
they don't have a sex it just means that
unlike 99.99 of population it's not as
immediately physically obvious because
of birth defects that they suffer from
genetic mutations
but
what do they have to do
with
with gay pride
why are they this is a medical condition
why is that included in the lgbt club
well the answer is simply because they
are useful
to
the lgbt club and specifically the t
because there's this um there's this
kind of conflation that goes on
between
trans people and intersex people those
are two completely separate categories
have nothing to do with each other
whatsoever
but they're useful and so that's why
whether they like it or not
they've been dragged onto the flag
the lgbt is saying to the intersex
people who just are people who suffer
from birth defects you're gonna be on
this flag whether you like it or not
we're putting you on it
because we can use you
we talk about the sleight of hand tricks
that's that's that is the game from lgbt
activists everything they do is a slight
hatred
you know um in the film
one of the questions that i get all the
time that they i was asked this on dr
phil as well i mean like you get this
question ever anytime you try to engage
on any of these issues what's what's
what's the um the rejoinder from the
left it's always why do you care so much
well that's a slight of handshake
because they start but i mean they're
they have a flag they have pride parades
they have a pride month
they're running around constantly waving
their hands in the air saying look at us
look at our sexuality you should care
about this care about us
and then the moment that you say okay
well sure
let's talk about it
then they said well why do you care so
much
because but you just said we should care
oh no no but you you want us to care in
the way that
you have a sign to us
and uh it's the same thing they do with
intersex
where they say well what about these
intersex people the sex is more
difficult to determine
and so that proves that that's uh that
this trans person's claims are valid
wait what what does that have to do with
anything
you know which quote trans woman is a
biological male
who says that he's a woman
whatever we say about intersex people
how do they in any way
lend validity to what this
what the trans person is saying
yet another sleight of hand trick
um
and that's uh i guess a little bit of a
digression i mean the main point is that
this is this is nascar putting this out
there as every single corporation every
company
bends the knee
and then
what
the public has to decide
is whether they're going to continue
supporting these kinds of companies
i mean
how many i'm not saying that there are
no lgbt people who are fans of nascar
but
how big is that portion of the audience
i wonder
probably pretty small
and so they're they are genuflecting to
this small minority no matter what the
majority happens to think it's up to the
majority to decide how they're going to
respond to that
all right this is from the daily wire
this is a story that i have
steadfastly ignored on this show but now
that it has reached its conclusion
i will
acknowledge it at least uh the daily
wire reports the jury on wednesday found
that actor johnny depp was defamed by
ex-wife amber heard and awarded him a
total of 15 million dollars in damages
the jury also awarded her 2 million in
monetary damages for her defamation
claim depp suit her for 50 million over
an op-ed she penned about domestic
violence at the washington post in 2018
the aquaman actress then countersued
for 100 million dollars and um the jury
came back and they gave this little
really just kind of a symbolic gesture
to amber heard with the two million but
um at the end of the day they were
vindicating johnny depp and saying that
this was defamation by the way
it is um it is very very difficult to
win a defamation case
okay i don't pretend to be a lawyer but
what i can tell you is that it's a very
difficult thing to win because the
burden of the the the number of elements
that you have to prove
creates this
burden that for in most cases is
insurmountable
you got to prove a lot of things but
first thing you have to prove obviously
is that what was said about you isn't
true because if it's true then it's not
defamation
so you're already in the position of you
have to prove a negative
you have to prove that you didn't do
something
and then you also have to prove that
this was said you know intentionally
maliciously you have to prove that it
caused you
actual harm and that there's some kind
of financial harm as well attached to
that so a lot of things you have to
prove the fact that uh the jury came
back this way is is
quite an indictment
um and it does prove that amber heard
was lying now amber heard has uh
released a statement immediately after
this
she says the disappointment i feel today
is beyond words i'm heartbroken that the
mountain of evidence still was not
enough to stand up to the
disproportionate power influence and
sway of my ex-husband i'm even more
disappointed with what this verdict
means for other women it's a setback it
sets back the clock to a time when a
woman who spoke up and spoke out could
be publicly shamed and humiliated it
sets back the idea that violence against
women is to be taken seriously
i believe johnny's attorney succeeded in
getting the jury to overlook the key
issue of freedom of speech and ignore
the evidence that was so conclusive that
we won in the uk well freedom of speech
has nothing to do with it because you do
not have the freedom to defame people
does this set back women no unless
you're the kind of woman who was
planning to make up malicious lies about
a man to destroy his life then yeah this
is a setback for you so in other words
this is a uh this is a setback to the
metoo movement not just a setback but
it's the utter and total
destruction of the metoo movement
um which was already probably on its
last legs and now it's just it's over
that's this is the end
uh this is the ignominious end of the of
the uh of the metoo movement
you know
obviously this
this slogan of believe all women was
absurd from the beginning
because of course you're not going to
believe
you believe someone based on the claim
that they're making and whether you find
it to be credible
because that's that's the first problem
with believe all women
the second problem is that you can't
really choose
so you can't have this principle of oh
i'm going to believe all of these sorts
of people no matter what they say that's
not how belief works
you can't make yourself believe
something that you don't if you want me
to believe something you have to
convince me
and then of course your belief should
not be uh dependent on the demographic
of the person making the claim and then
as well
everybody who said believe all women
none of them actually believed it
now what they always meant was believe
certain women
uh with uh who have who hold certain
ideological views who make certain kinds
of claims in certain situations believe
them
but i think the other thing we take away
from this is that um
what we have to remember is amber heard
is a is a leftist
johnny depp i think probably is too
i think for certain he is but amber hurt
is
and you know leftism
gives people the license to lie
and so that's what something that's been
wrapped up in the metoo movement
in the believe all women stuff
because why are you supposed to believe
all women
because the the idea is that if a woman
again certain women it's all it's all
ideologically dependent
but if she says something
then that's her truth it's how she feels
and so it is your responsibility to
believe it
this is the leftist claim
and it gives you a license to lie
because it's not a lie
actually under leftism it's impossible
to lie because whatever you say that's
just your truth that's how you felt
so as far as amber heard was concerned
yeah was she actually physically abused
by johnny depp no
but she feels like she was
it would be convenient for her now if
she was and so she was
that's uh that's the way it works all
right let's move to this speaking of of
lies
and the lies in this case that parents
tell their
children so libs of tick tock had this
video that went viral yesterday
um
and something that you know as what is
woman comes out this is just more
evidence as to why the film what is
woman is needed here is um two parents
talking about
how their two-year-old
chose
i believe her gender this is a girl who
now quote identifies as a boy and what
was the process by which this
two-year-old
came to this gender realization let's
listen
are you ready
on the 6th of march we welcomed our
beautiful twins into the world a boy
called arlo and a girl called emerald
the first one they said was this is a
girl i genuinely remember your face just
like lighting up like this is amazing
and then the next one is on this is a
boy
jackpot you know one of each this is the
perfect combination here
look at that
so now they're four years old and
they identify as two boys
the first time that i realized stormy
wanted to identify as male was about
roughly two and a half but
it's not really he said i want to be a
boy he said i am a boy
and that is the difference
my name is stormy and i'm four years old
i feel like a boy and i want to be a boy
sometimes people call me girl
do they how does that make you feel sad
i can't remember the exact moment it
switched over but there was that point
where i thought you know what this isn't
just this isn't just a phase this is not
a little girl we're looking at it's a
little boy
he started being unhappy with being
dressed as a girl who started being
unhappy wearing dresses hair clips were
a big no-no didn't like hair clips
didn't like the pigtails he was
genuinely
upset at being dressed as a girl before
i had children and certainly before the
last couple of years this whole thing
that i'm saying i would have thought it
was ridiculous honestly i would i would
have i would have watched me
and said no you you you're crazy you're
making it up you're abusing a child
we constantly say are you a boy today or
do you feel like you might because i
don't want you to feel like you took
himself down a route that you can't turn
back
uh
i mean to begin it's you don't even know
where to begin with these people let me
just say first of all the story that
that guy tells who is an abuser and both
of these people should be in prison
he he claims oh before i had uh this
child i i would have been i would have
seen this and said that that's abusive
and
i was very skeptical no no no you
weren't that's that's a lie of course
because there's just no way i mean if
you're two-year-old if you're taking
your two-year-old seriously about this
it's because this is what you want
there's just no way that your
two-year-old convinced you
of something like this
and he also says that
well we realized it's not just a phase
really from two
so this started when your
daughter
was two years old
now she's four years old and in between
that time you realize that it's not a
phase
how could that possibly be the case
phases for little kids can last they can
last five seconds they can last a couple
years depends
it's the whole the notion of taking a
two-year-old seriously about anything my
daughter's two years old
she um
and this is true she constantly like
every day she she tells and she tells
the this story especially around the the
dinner table um she'll kind of my
two-year-old daughter will dominate the
dinner table conversation every night
now
because she tells she's these these
fantastical stories she tells us about
all the monkeys that are in her room and
she's she's we went to the it was we
went to the rainforest cafe which is
always a mistake we went there
a few few months ago and they've got the
animatronic monkeys flying around and
ever since then she's had this she's
been latched on to that this idea of
like monkeys being around and in her
room and so anyway that's the story that
she tells every day
and sometimes the monkeys are doing
different things and sometimes most the
time they're in her room sometimes they
like they crawl into the crib with her
sometimes it's like different different
versions of the story
and is it so what is what is my
two-year-old daughter doing when she
tells the story about the about the
monkeys
is she is she lying is she trying to
deceive us no
um is she using her imagination yes but
does she see it that way no because for
her
as i'm constantly hammering on this
point at the age of two
there there is no
conscious distinction between fantasy
and reality they don't see the
distinction
so as far as she's concerned yeah there
are monkeys in her room
does that mean that she's hallucinating
i guess not i mean it's hard to get
inside the mind of a two-year-old to
know exactly how it works not a few of a
few few of us can remember what it's
like for us when we're two
but what we do know for sure is that
they just do not have a grasp on reality
which is why you can't
take this seriously obviously
but these parents know that
i'm sitting here arguing against it
trying to explain why oh no
she's she's two this is what a
two-year-old does well they know that
but this is what they wanted of their
child
i mean notice how they say like it's
hard for me to believe they even cut the
video together like this but um
the father says well or maybe it's the
mother
she didn't say i want to be a boy
she said i am a boy
and then in the very next scene what do
we hear from the child
i want to be a boy
this is uh
a sane society takes those people and
puts them in prison this is
this is abuse on every level it's it's
every brand of abuse right it's
psychological abuse emotional abuse
spiritual abuse
it's physical abuse and it is sexual
abuse it is all of those things wrapped
into one
and it's all of those things kind of on
the on the deepest level
where you are
violating a child's sense
of identity of who they are you're
taking that away from them
permanently potentially
oh but we we give her a choice
every day we ask are you a boy today
so she can make a decision
it's really up to her
well no because you are the one
assigning her
this like version this twisted
fantastical version of reality
where your identity is not fixed and
it's fluid
and it changes by the day
so you're you're giving her that to her
that's the curse that you're giving to
her
um
all right let's go here's a interesting
story from fox news it says a former uh
virginia tech football player was
acquitted of murder charges friday in
the deadly beating of a man accused of
pretending to be a woman during a sexual
encounter after the two matched on
tinder a jury montgomery county circuit
court found 19 year old
is
sure i'm getting that wrong not guilty
of a charge of second-degree murder the
2021 death of jerry smith uh jerry smith
40 of blacksburg so there's a 40 year
old man jerry smith who was killed by
the 19 year old man
jury deliberated for three hours um
prosecutors had earlier told the jury
that etudes then a team became enraged
and fatally beat smith when he
discovered smith was a man
smith who identified as a gay man
presented himself in a profile on the
online dating app tinder as a 21 year
old emergency room physician named angie
renee
smith performed oral sex on it too to
later return to the department to find
out if his date was a man or a woman
um and taking the standard early week of
two had testified that he felt violated
and then it came it turned out that the
man the older man smith had uh had a had
a knife under his mattress and so this
was like
um
the defense attorneys argued that etude
had acted in self-defense whereas smith
had been controlling the entire
environment in the entire episode and
demanded it be in the dark and had a
knife hidden under his mattress in case
there was there was something awry
now
maybe not surprisingly
lgbt news outlets like the advocate and
pink news
are not happy about this i mean they are
not happy
that uh this guy isn't going to jail
they call this a quote gay panic defense
but no what this actually is is um
this is this is rape so this man was
raped
when you trick somebody into a sexual
encounter with you
uh especially when you have a knife on
standby but even if you don't that is
that is rape and they're entitled to
self-defense which is apparently what
the jury decided there
um now
the jury came this inclusion i haven't
followed the case at all and this is the
first time hearing about it
so
i'm going to assume they looked at all
of this i just on the surface
there is some skepticism that that you
might have like how could you not know
that a 40-year-old man
is not a 20-year-old woman how could you
possibly have be fooled by that
but that's what the jury decided and
assuming that he was then this was rape
and self defense pretty clear cut okay
so we have um one more thing here this
is another story
that you're just gonna have to sit and
listen to damn it whether you like it or
not it says a star in deep space this is
from daily wire a star in deep space
from a neutron star graveyard is
emitting a strange pulse that is
intriguing scientists who didn't expect
to detect any radio emissions at all
from that area roughly 1 300 light years
from earth in the vela x1 region of the
milky way psr
j09414046 emitted a pulse that lasted
about 300 milliseconds and repeated
every 76 seconds but most neutron star
pulses cycle through every few seconds
or less so it's a very
weird thing they're trying to figure out
university of sydney lecturer manisha
caleb says this wasn't like anything
we'd seen before we might have found a
completely new class of radio emitting
object
our observation showed psr j09414046
had some of the characteristics of a
pulsar even a magnetar
but they're still not exactly sure what
the object is so this is fascinating
okay first of all think about the
distances involved here i mean we're we
are detecting activity from 300 light
years away which is like that's a hop
skip and a jump in galactic terms but in
mileage i mean a light year is about 6
trillion miles right so this is we're
talking about six
six thousand trillion miles which i
believe will be six quadrillion miles
the distances are vast
space is is big okay it's very it's big
and that's and that should fascinate you
and uh think about think about the time
of involved here
okay think a pulsar is a neutron star
which which is is a star that has has
died and collapsed in on itself uh much
like western civilization has here but
that means that this star lived for
billions of years and died and there's
there's a whole story there that we'll
never know potentially millions of
civilizations lived and died in the
solar system all those trillions of
miles away so there's a there's a story
there that's just sad and beautiful and
immense and mysterious
so do you understand
why this should interest you
and then one day our son will die and
become a red giant and mercury and venus
will be totally consumed in its fire and
our planet will be scorched to ash and
all life will die and be extinguished on
this planet and other civilizations and
other solar systems will watch this
happen but they'll see it only as a
light in the sky never knowing
the epic tale
that was told
and that ended
and that was forgotten
in the dark vastness
of space
so just like get into this stuff guys
okay
if you're a business owner you know
better than anybody that it is
absolutely crucial to have an effective
marketing strategy and here's the good
news i have something to help you with
that constant contact constant contact
is a digital marketing platform that
helps small businesses and nonprofits of
all sizes build grow and succeed with
email marketing contact management
industry leading list growth tools
social media ads and more constant
contact help small businesses connect
with customers find new ones and sell
online all this from one easy to use
platform they've been trusted by
millions of businesses to help improve
their marketing with a 97 deliverability
rate you can rest assured that your
customers and potential customers are
getting the right message at the right
time with a simple interface constant
contact's easy to use platform makes
contact management easier than ever
their list growth tools help you find a
bigger audience fast and with thousands
of integrations you can sync constant
contacts tools with the tools you're
already using so it's very easy powerful
automation tools help you send the right
message to the right person at the right
time every time so to start your free
digital marketing trial today visit
constantcontact.com
let's get to the comment section
cybercop says today was one of the
biggest or rather the best episodes yet
can't wait for what is a woman i hope
the media gets triggered by it
um so more people have a chance to wake
up yes there's quite a lot of
a lot of triggering going on
will you that that we can be quite sure
of um
another comment says matt a few years
ago i was very left-wing and
self-identified feminist the thing that
started to push me away from the left
was trans ideology and seeing what was
happening to women that the mainstream
so-called feminists were defending the
feminists who actually cared enough
about women to speak out were abused
slandered fired etc the final straw for
me was learning about violent men being
put in women's prisons where these women
who so often have a history of trauma
literally cannot escape i've moved
pretty far away from my old ideology
over the past few years i no longer seek
out a clean just so ideology to follow
i'm a lot more comfortable making up my
own mind about individual stories but
one thing that stood out to me through
all this is that so many people who
actually respect women and care about
them as human beings are actually
conservative i never would have believed
this several years ago the left makes
you believe that virtually all men and
certainly all conservatives hate women
and
think of them as less than men well
first of all congratulations on on uh
being someone willing to
use your your brain
and be skeptical
and at least entertain
the possibility that you you might be
wrong about even some of your most
deeply held fundamental fundamental
beliefs
most people aren't willing to even
entertain that possibility and that's
why there can't be any kind of
conversation there can't be anything
that approaches an actual debate
um because of that
but of course you're also right that
um
as conservatives are slandered as being
the woman haters it couldn't be more
absurd or more or more
sort of the opposite of the truth
as conservatives what are we trying to
conserve
well that that is a a question that i
think we need we need to do a better job
amongst ourselves of answering but i
have an answer for it
uh the first thing we want to conserve
is just the truth the fundamental truth
of reality
both physical scientific truths which
are under attack and moral truths as
well
we're trying to conserve
the family
and and human dignity is another another
big thing we want to conserve as
conservatives
so this is a this is a belief system
that is rooted
in a in an understanding of and respect
for
the dignity of the human person
whereas the left just does not see it
that way they don't think that human
beings are that have you know have
intrinsic value or inherent dignity
they can't believe that
because if you believe that then you
couldn't support
killing 60 million unborn babies and
throwing them in dumpsters
so it's no surprise that we're the ones
who respect women because we respect
people humanity right
um
kathy with a c says i elold as matt was
asking those questions of the tribesmen
how did he manage to keep a straight
face you know that was one of the uh
tougher interactions
because
even me
you know i'm usually pretty stone cold
when it comes to these things but even
even i had moments where i where i
wanted to laugh if you could believe but
then also there was a little bit of a
pride thing
where i knew when they were laughing
right they were actually laughing at me
i mean they were laughing at the
insanity of western
culture and what it's become the tragic
insanity of it they're laughing at that
but they're also laughing really
personally at me because they they
thought that i was a proponent of these
ideas or they thought at a minimum that
i was actually confused
about these things
um and i i kind of wanted to pull them
to the side and say hey i don't really
believe this stuff just so you know i'm
not one of those guys okay i'm just
asking the questions but then if you
tell them that then you lose a lot of
the authenticity in the interaction so i
didn't want to tell them that so
they just assumed that i was an absolute
maniac personally
and they still think that now and that's
that's okay it was all worth it for the
film
which you can go to what is woman.com to
watch right now
i'm sure you've probably noticed because
uh it's impossible to not notice this is
one of those things that really just
affects everybody is that gas prices are
ridiculously high right now and uh you
may feel like so it's a little bit
suffocating at times every time you're
at the pump you're looking for a way out
well um here's one there's an incredible
app everyone who buys gas needs to know
about and that is called upside my
listeners are earning cash back for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free upside app in
the app store or google play right now
use promo code walsh for 25 cents per
gallon or more on your first fill up get
cash back as well you may feel like
there's no upside anymore when you're
popping gas but here is this is it it's
the upside up don't pay full price of
the pump anymore get cash back using
upside just download the app for free
and use promo code walsh for 25 cents
per gallon or more on your first tank
and it's not just for gas you can earn
cash back at grocery stores restaurants
and with your take out also you can cash
out any time to your bank account or an
e-gift card for select retailers and
brands just download the free upside app
and use promo code walsh to get 25 cents
per gallon or more cash back on your
first tank just use my my promo code
walsh now that's code walsh
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation after
uh tackling some tough subjects on the
show there's nothing wrong with taking a
layup here um this is an easy one though
still worthy of the segment here is a
tick tock user who goes by the handle
little trans punk
explaining how your sexual attraction is
supposed to work trans punk will tell
you
who you are supposed to be attracted to
so this is his decision after all he's
trans punk he's the authority
listen to trans punk
all right i will assume that you asked
this question in the way that you really
want to learn so i will explain all the
ways that it is okay
let's say that you're attracted to women
well if you're attracted to a woman then
you're attracted to assess women trans
women without bottom surgery and trans
women with
bottom surgery if you're attracted to
um vj then you could be attracted to a
cis moment a trans man without bottom
surgery a trans woman with bottom
surgery or
a non-binary person which depending on
their assigned gender at birth having or
not having had the surgery but it is
that exclusion that makes it
transphobic
so if you say that you like women and
you like bj
then that would mean that you are
attracted to cis women and trans women
who have had who have had bottom surgery
it is just that exclusion
that makes it transphobic you can have a
genital preference but to exclude trans
people is transphobic
ah so uh you see you know all that stuff
about how it's none of your business
what people do in the bedroom sexual
orientation isn't a choice anyone can
love whoever they want etc all of that
was nonsense of course well qualified
nonsense at least it's none of your
business what people do in the bedroom
but it is the business of trans punk and
his friends
you can't tell people who to love but
trans activists can
they can do all sorts of things that you
cannot do because they're special or so
they think so a few points to make here
first of all of course um needless to
say
what is a woman trans punk says that if
we're attracted to women we must also be
attracted to women with penises but
okay what does he think a woman is
he would probably say as they all do
that a woman is anybody who identifies
as a woman and that's a circular and
logically invalid definition
but it also raises questions about
sexual attraction so
when somebody says they're attracted to
women he thinks that what they're
attracted to is the woman's
self-perception
no attraction is defined the other way
if you're attracted to somebody you're
attracted based on your perception of
them not their perception of themselves
obviously
also you notice how the people who
lecture you for not being attracted to
them
seem to go out of their way to be
unattractive
they make themselves ugly and then blame
you for not finding them beautiful
they pierce their faces take on the
clown makeup and do everything in their
power to look as ridiculous as possible
and they scream in your face be
attracted to me you bigot
it's all a game
you know their ugliness becomes a test
of your wokeness
they make themselves into a sort of
left-wing hazing ritual
they paint their hair green they wear
their bizarre war paint and then they
tell you that you must sleep with them
in order to be initiated into the cult
because if you don't then you're
transphobic
which is why perhaps
a good response to this sort of thing
is to simply say
well okay
then i guess i'm transphobic
you're admitting that you're transphobic
you confess to the charge
sure
whatever fine
i don't care
the labels you use mean nothing to me
i'm not going to cower and tremble and
desperately try to prove my innocence to
you
i don't care if you think i'm guilty of
whatever category of crime you just made
up
i don't care how you see me
okay you have no power here
you can't manipulate me
you can't make me dance to this tune
you're playing
call me what you want doesn't matter
see in reality the term transphobia
means nothing it's a nonsense term
by design empty of meaning
so that they can go they can give it
whatever meaning they want in whatever
situation
and now this person says that
transphobia means not being attracted to
him well
you made up the term so i guess you can
make up the definition and if that's the
definition not being attracted to you
then sure that's me guilty as
so now
we can now that we've established that
you're transphobic okay
sure whatever
so
okay
that that's done
we can either move on and the
conversation can progress or you can sit
there babbling the word transphobia over
and over again while you curl into the
fetal position and rock yourself back
and forth it's up to you
the main point here is that just as we
discussed at the top of the show
they only have the power that we give
them
free yourself from the fear of being
labeled labeled
free yourself from any desire
to be accepted by the woke crowd
just let that go
and they will be totally disarmed
they will be reduced to sound and fury
signifying nothing
just as you can see in my film what is a
woman available now at what is woman.com
and that is all why our friend transpunc
is today canceled and we'll leave it
there for today
uh that'll do it for us have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
today on the ben shapiro show amber
heard is found to be a liar and a
slanderer and the washington post
doesn't have clean hands either the star
wars universe unites against the phantom
menace of widespread racism and the
american military celebrates pride month
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen